we're going to begin this hour with the
nationwide increase in covet cases and
hospitalization the highly contagious ba
5 subvariant now accounts for about 78
of all covet infections in this country
the cdc says we're averaging more than
120 000 cases a day but since many
people are testing at home the actual
number is probably much higher than that
we asked you to share your questions
about this latest covet threat dr celine
gander is here to answer what you've
sent to us she's an epidemiologist and
our contributor from kff's kaiser health
news where she's editor at large good
morning to you dr celine gowner good to
have you here you know the thing about
people testing at home the never has to
be higher because i could see people
taking the test and say i'm going to
keep this to myself this positive
diagnosis don't you think well it's not
just that they're keeping it to
themselves there's actually no way for
them to report those numbers those test
results to the local health department
to the cdc there's nobody
yeah exactly who do you call all right
we're going to start with sarah
elizabeth she's on instagram very good
question sarah elizabeth because this is
exactly what i was thinking she asked
this if i had coveted in the last three
months will i have immunity against this
variant so if you got covid three months
ago it's very likely you had the ba2
variant which is an earlier variant the
ba5 variant is so different from all the
variants all the omicron variants that
came before it it's very unlikely you
have much in the way of protection
from that prior infection i think big
picture you should be if you're eligible
so people who are eligible for a second
booster are people who are 50 and up
or 12 and up and immunocompromised you
should go and get that second booster
now so when did that b5 variant kick in
then if you said if you had it three
months ago what if you had it say first
week of june yeah so essentially in the
last month or so we've seen the rise of
ba-4 ba-5 ba-5 seems to be out running
ba-4
constituting about three-quarters of
cases now
are we gonna picking up on a question
here uh from a viewer on twitter is
there at some point going to be a
specific vaccine for ba5 or kind of the
all-purpose flour like we're just going
to cover them all with one shot very
good question we want that yeah right
moderna and pfizer both working on these
updated combo vaccines that will include
the original formulation as well as a
ba-5 component
those will not be available until
probably late october early november
so if you're eligible for a booster now
don't wait for that one you'll still be
able to get that one in terms of these
universal coronavirus vaccines i think
that's the holy grail right that would
protect you against all the variants we
unfortunately are several years away
from having something like that we don't
have an operation warp speed to really
marshal resources to get that done now
you mentioned vaccines for people over
50 federal health officials are
reportedly considering opening up a
second booster for younger healthier
people under 50. so for those who are at
home saying okay i'm young i'm healthy
i've been vaccinated boosted why would i
need a second booster it's a very good
question there's actually a lot of
debate among scientists as to whether to
open this up or not so this is very
contentious
i think they probably will open up to
people under 50. um myself i'm under 50
i'm not going to get a second booster
now i will
i just don't think you need it based on
the data um you know if you're young
you're healthy you don't have underlying
um chronic medical conditions you're not
immunocompromised
you know you're not really seeing a
benefit in terms of prevention of severe
disease so so would you wait for the one
in the fall without your recommendation
if you're under 50 yeah healthy not
immunocompromised i would say wait for
the updated booster in the fall okay
that's valuable information yeah good
info uh oh you're under 50 people yes
on instagram kaylee says what do we know
about this variant and the severity for
children
so we don't know that much about ba five
uh in children per se but what i would
say is i think a lot of people think
covet is harmless in kids it is not
harmless in kids it's not so kids
between the ages of six months and four
years so that's the age group that just
became eligible for vaccination they've
had 20 000 really over 20 000
hospitalizations from covid during the
pandemic 200 or so have died these are
preventable
tragedy tragedies so parents really
should get their children vaccinated as
soon as possible
uh teddy got his first shot just a
couple days ago three how to go uh
really well
daddy's three uh teddy cries all the
time he got ice cream yesterday and then
cried because i wouldn't give him a
second ice cream and a different flavor
right away
but this is the amazing thing didn't cry
when he got the copic shot like
apparently he's immune to pain wow he's
a tough cookie he thought he was gonna
get ice cream teddy knows he's doing the
right thing tony he did get two
lollipops though he couldn't win the
thing oh he works anyway yeah he did
good thank you dr sling gonna appreciate
it